as rivals and competitors.
So Israel, who in the 1980s
lobbied for and improved U.S.-Iran relations
now feared a U.S.-Iran rapprochement,
thinking that it would come
at Israel's security interests' expense,
and instead sought to put Iran
in increased isolation.
Ironically, this was happening at a time
when Iran was more interested
in peacemaking with Washington
than to see to Israel's destruction.
Iran had put itself in isolation
because of its radicalism,
and after having helped the United States indirectly
in the war against Iraq in 1991,
the Iranians were hoping
that they would be rewarded by being included
in the post-war security architecture of the region.
But Washington chose to ignore Iran's outreach,
as it would a decade later in Afghanistan,
and instead moved to intensify Iran's isolation,
and it is at this point, around 1993, '94,
that Iran begins to translate
its anti-Israeli ideology
into operational policy.
The Iranians believed that whatever they did,
even if they moderated their policies,
the U.S. would continue to seek Iran's isolation,
and the only way Iran could compel Washington
to change its position was by imposing a cost
on the U.S. if it didn't.
The easiest target was the peace process,
and now the Iranian ideological bark
was to be accompanied by a nonconventional bite,
and Iran began supporting extensively
Palestinian Islamist groups that it previously
had shunned.
In some ways, this sounds paradoxical,
but according to Martin Indyk
of the Clinton administration,
the Iranians had not gotten it entirely wrong,
because the more peace there would be
between Israel and Palestine,
the U.S. believed, the more Iran would get isolated.
The more Iran got isolated, the more peace there would be.
So according to Indyk, and these are his words,
the Iranians had an interest to do us in
on the peace process
in order to defeat our policy of containment.
To defeat our policy of containment,
not about ideology.
But throughout even the worst times of their entanglement,
all sides have reached out to each other.
Netanyahu, when he got elected in 1996,
reached out to the Iranians to see
if there were any ways that
the doctrine of the periphery could be resurrected.
Tehran was not interested.
A few years later, the Iranians sent
a comprehensive negotiation proposal to the Bush administration,
a proposal that revealed that there was some potential
of getting Iran and Israel back on terms again.
The Bush administration did not even respond.
All sides have never missed an opportunity
to miss an opportunity.
But this is not an ancient conflict.
This is not even an ideological conflict.
The ebbs and flows of hostility
have not shifted with ideological zeal,
but rather with changes in the geopolitical landscape.
When Iran and Israel's security imperatives
dictated collaboration, they did so
in spite of lethal ideological opposition to each other.
When Iran's ideological impulses collided
with its strategic interests,
the strategic interests always prevailed.
This is good news, because it means
that neither war nor enmity
is a foregone conclusion.
But some want war.
Some believe or say that it's 1938,
Iran is Germany,
and Ahmadinejad is Hitler.
If we accept this to be true,
that indeed it is 1938, Iran is Germany,
Ahmadinejad is Hitler,
then the question we have to ask ourself is,
who wishes to play the role of Neville Chamberlain?
Who will risk peace?
This is an analogy that is deliberately aimed
at eliminating diplomacy,
and when you eliminate diplomacy,
you make war inevitable.
In an ideological conflict, there can be no truce,
no draw, no compromise,
only victory or defeat.
But rather than making war inevitable
by viewing this as ideological,
we would be wise to seek ways
to make peace possible.
Iran and Israel's conflict is a new phenomenon,
only a few decades old
in a history of 2,500 years,
and precisely because its roots are geopolitical,
it means that solutions can be found,
compromises can be struck,
however difficult it yet may be.
After all, it was Yitzhak Rabin himself who said,
"You don't make peace with your friends.
You make it with your enemies."
Thank you.
(Applause)